this video is sponsored by Azure lane
back in the prehistoric era historians
now like to refer to as 2006 internet
culture was still in its infancy and a
young gig up would indulge in an
activity that would eventually blossom
to a worldwide pastime we all hold truly
dear to our hearts watching stupid
Internet videos Numa Numa guy is the
badger song these were the first real
viral hits that ever existed but one
genre that was always popular came in
the form of parody animations I can't
tell you how much time I wasted as a
[ __ ] Kid browsing the feature tab on
Newgrounds breaking the replay button on
ultimate showdown and the Star Wars rap
rewatching middle gear awesome so many
times that every line is now permanently
etched into my brain so it was only a
matter of time before we got this silly
parody niche that catered towards the
small but growing anime community and
that came in the form of a bridge series
a bridge series were the staple of anime
parodies on YouTube above amv creators
above fan dubbers above cover artists
above anime reviewers if he had a
popular bridge series you are the rock
stars of the anime fandom these are
people that I looked up enough to that
even I got influenced to try to have a
little dabble in abridging even if I
didn't fully dive into the community so
today I wanted to make a video
spotlighting the history and evolution
of a bridge series and star my own
little appreciation threads to everyone
that took the time to become a part of
this community and even inspired me
directly in some of the content that
I've made so before we get started on
the history of abridging I wanted to
give a quick shout out to our sponsor
for this video so we don't get
distracted later as your lane is a
side-scrolling shoot-'em-up extravaganza
that has taken Japan China and most of
Asia by storm and has recently made its
way over here to the west and has
already garnered a very active community
and following you take control of a
group of World War 2 battleships yes
these are based on real-life historical
ships this is exactly what d-day looks
like in a bullet hail style shooter as
you fly your way through the story mode
which is both fun and challenging as you
progress but look I'm not gonna lie to
you alright we all know why we're here
it's about ship girls baby and
to say all the girls here are top-tier
because you see if you want to win
battles the tactical strategy is to
build ships with thick armor right now
we're going through the divergent
chessboard event which includes the
highly anticipated iron Vlad girls
becoming available and new special
edition Christmas skins just to get you
in the festive mood click the link below
to join the sensation today on iOS or
Android and with that said let's get
back to talking about the history of
abridging and so I think a good place to
start with is the beginning I don't know
where else you expected me to start the
grandfather of abridging was one little
kuriboh with the first bridge series
ever made that is still running to this
day yugioh abridged the series laid out
the groundwork for what in the bridge
series was and how it differentiated
itself from other parodies the basic
format of taking a whole actual yugioh
episode condensing it down to his core
plot points and re dubbing it with
funnier dialogue looking back now this
was the most basic of parodies that are
dwarfed by some of the stuff coming out
today but in an era of YouTube poops and
rickrolled videos listed out something
that was quality content and LK rose in
popularity really quickly he wasn't the
first person to do anime parody dubs but
what he did do was give the basic format
and a catchy name and I'm gonna be
honest with you before a bridge series
ever existed I didn't even know what the
meaning of the word a bridge was [ __ ]
off Siri nobody asked you what this
meant is that others could replicate
this format to other shows which they
did but this was the Wild West of
abridging were acceptable quality
equated to shouting as many references
as you could into a $5 Walmart's mic
with the odd musical montage which of
course meant he had the theme of you
spin me round' by dead or alive whenever
there was a character spinning round
with our envies and memes and why did
everyone use this [ __ ] song I'm funny
about this a bridge series with some of
the only anime related content on
YouTube as a time you know when you want
to just strike it up watching anime
illegally uploaded with the three
separate parts [ __ ] crunchyroll this was
the real anime streaming service even so
a few series managed to stand up
thanks to their quality of writing and
voice acting that was a cut above the
rest
you had Moscow X and Vegeta 3986 dude
Naruto Lani patata YuYu Hakusho hvit
Ches berserk Kaiser mecha with loop on
the third Tejada 101 G Gundam amigami 33
doing Sailor Moon if these names sound
familiar to you it's because many of
them would go on to become the founding
fathers for the group that would change
the approaching season forever Dragon
Ball Z abridge premiered by the group
team for star who was essentially a
supergroup formed by taka Lani and
Kaiser with a voice help from everyone
else I mentioned and I remember when
they first announced this I was hype as
[ __ ] you had the abridging superstars
assembling to tackle one of the most
beloved anime franchises in the West
there were almost like The Avengers of
abridging before Avengers even came out
[Music]
now I don't know who's that makes
Donaldson all this way
wait a minute
[Music]
with such a dream team of content
creators coming together to work on a
project expectations were high and boy
did they [ __ ] deliver
I really can't understate how much team
four star and DBZ a bridge completely
revolutionized the scene not only by
skyrocketing the popularity of a bridge
series even outside of our normally
small anime community but also by
raising the level of production quality
that became a benchmark that everyone
would try to reach but would rarely ever
be matched and I'd time me like oh yes
you know I mean they [ __ ] destroy
everything that came before it's in
every level of production quality and
they did this in a time when it was
still acceptable to upload 240p on
youtube that's right all of season 1 of
DBZ a bridge is not even 360p that's how
[ __ ] old it is your professional
level voice acting that was done by a
team and not just one person writing the
focused less on cheap referential humour
and more on character based comedy
proper sound design aka Nobby to this
they still knows how to make footsteps
not sound like complete ass
crunch-crunch-crunch
wow I didn't know my characters are
walking through a [ __ ] road of Karel
crossings and competent visuals which of
course means the bane of every abridges
life editing [ __ ] that flap so they
sync to the audio you know I'm glad
we've grown past the point where
parodies would try to accurately match
every lip flap syllable for syllable
resulting in conversations where lips
look like two machine guns having
conversations with each other
but even with the more natural dub look
it's still one of the most
time-consuming parts of the process so
on behalf of every abridge I would like
to personally thank everyone a team for
star but especially the incredibly
talented chief editor Kaiser Necco for
revolutionizing the editing techniques
that many of us employ an ARB which work
today
allons draining so many hours of our
lives syncing up lip flaps you know
making our sit through days of opening
and closing opening and closing again
pasting the same three [ __ ] frames
over and over
key framing movies and finding missing
limb flaps and color correcting the flap
did you do it geyser why do you hate us
is that it from there on everyone
changed and the bridge series became a
household name a bridging eventually
just became a synonym for dubbed anime
parody which didn't even always a bridge
a show you'd find plenty of parodies
that were even longer than the source
material would covered or videos that
didn't have anything to do for the plot
it's like some idiots didn't even know
what the meaning of the word abridged
was Barker this was at the height of its
popularity and it got a bit
oversaturated we could have five
different people walking on separate a
bridge series for the same show and
every anime Under the Sun had an
abridged series to its name even though
90% of them were complete [ __ ] because
of how widespread it was it's kind of
hard to pinpoint any group or individual
who stood out because there were just so
many different people doing so many
different things but there were a few
who managed to make a name for
themselves purple eyes WTF was one of
the first person who was able to
differentiate himself for the unique
spell that put every viewer at risk of
capturing ADHD what do you mean you're
at soup I mean I'm app so what store are
you in I'm at the soup store why are you
buying clothes at the soup store queue
and it was [ __ ] amazing but aside
from him we had other people like flares
bank and romper a bridge up to past
future cent octo path also PIMs 50% off
pokemon bridge double the North Star and
so so many other people that I'm not
gonna be able to name in this video you
even had some to get do this little
series called Ava bridge you remember
Ava bridge - everyone remembers Ava
bridged not that
many people are emailing bridge nobody
remembers they've abridged I don't know
a abridged for the top come on if this
video to be ones the next favor bridged
because projects got more ambitious it
became much more common practice to have
teams working together and I feel this
is where the abridging community really
started to form which in my eyes started
the second wave of younger bridges you
have people that specialized in writing
and editing your the species known as
voice actors who are easy to spot in the
wild because they all had the letters VA
at the end of their usernames this is no
shade thrown to anyone it's all by the
way everyone did it I mean how am I
supposed to know if you do voice work if
you don't have the letters VA at the end
of your username then there was also the
rare mineral that would surface every
now and again a female voice actress who
would then go to voice in about 20
different series because there are only
about five of them at any given time the
presence of this community generally
pushed the overall quality of abridging
to an all-time high because you had
courageous sharing advice and resources
even if no one reached the quality of
team four star you can have really small
creators churning out high-quality stuff
and newbies improving incredibly quickly
due to the advice and information that
was available last series i want to talk
about is sword ask for line abridge buy
something witty entertainment to me sao
abridge encapsulate how far a bridging
can go they are the only group that to
me have maybe even surpassed team four
star in terms of production value
because it's the only series I know of
that completely rewrote its source
material to make it by far a better
series than the original product it was
based on from writing to
characterization Sao Bridge is just
straight up a better version of Sao and
nobody even needed to glom two years
worth for Seema to have that all said
where is a bridging today well it would
be presumptuous to say that a bridging
is dead I think it's pretty clear that
it's well past the heights of popularity
used to have and I can kind of explain
why firstly there's one obvious problem
you know that moment when you spend
weeks
baking a pie and then just as you're
about to show that pie off to other
people someone smack out your hands and
goes no you can't show that pie to other
people you don't own that pie I own that
pie and then they start dancing
so all that's left is your broken tie
related hopes and dreams that will never
ever gonna get back well that's the
YouTube copyright system [ __ ] in an RG
copyright became a massive hindrance for
anyone who wants to upload parody
content on YouTube and there's really
nothing more off-putting for a content
creator than spending hours and hours of
your life working on a project that's
probably gonna be taken down secondly a
bridging became a victim of its own
success the standard of quality now is
so high that any newbie would have to
invest a massive amount of time just to
acquire the skills to make a competent
episode and most of the existing bridges
have just kind of moved on episodes now
take months to produce even for those
who can do it full-time which not only
doesn't suit the new YouTube algorithm
but is a massive time commitment which a
lot of people in the community who have
grown up and graduated or got jobs no
longer have to spare eventually the only
ones who are able to continue doing a
bridging regularly are those who are
able to support themselves financially
via patreon or other means which pretty
much only equates to a handful of people
and even then it's not always stable
this has made evident by team four star
themselves always having to cancel DBZ a
bridge earlier this year if they
couldn't stabili support themselves from
their other projects so really who the
[ __ ] would be stupid enough to go down
this career path anyway when you can
spend years of your life actually
getting a good education and building up
a stable career path basically in other
words either retire in a bridge er or
you live long enough to see yourself
become a nanny tuber so why did I want
to make a video about bridging why
should anyone want to get into a
bridging now anyway well speaking from
personal experience a bridge and parody
work is some of the most rewarding
content I've ever had a pleasure of
working on it is a ridiculous amount of
work but when it comes together there is
no other feeling like it and with this
entire community there is so much
genuine talent and skill that goes
behind making a good a bridge series but
that's so easy to forget behind the
funny memes and catchphrases and I
wanted to remind people of that
to prove this you need look no further
than those who have been able to use a
bridging as a stepping stone for bigger
things namely LK and the guys at team
four star who have not only gotten
opportunities to become a part of this
industry doing profession
voicework but has also paved the way for
someone like myself to be able to make a
living doing animate content on YouTube
which I couldn't be more grateful for
Team 4 star are just on the cusp of
releasing that first officially dubbed
anime hell's and for a group that
started off by doing silly anime
parodies that's pretty [ __ ] awesome
overall long-form abridged series may be
nowhere near as prominent but anime
parodies are just as strong as ever
abridging didn't really die so much that
he just evolved back into anime parodies
was it that be the occasional one-shot
or a slight twist to the formula so if
anyone feels inspired or wants to binge
on some parodies right now like my amv
video I'll put a playlist in the
description for some of my favorite
works old and new that I think deserve a
bit more love I would love to see more
people get into a bridge and parody work
because it's fun as [ __ ] and I will
never tire of a good parody so if my
talk about time sinks and lip flaps put
you off don't worry I would teach you a
shortcuts I've learned for all these
years that will guarantee to save you
some time it's pretty simple you see you
see the first step is just to put the
audio you need to sync in your timeline
in whatever editing software you choose
then the next step is just to simply hey
guys hope you enjoyed the video thank
you again - as your lane for sponsoring
me today and also thank you to Mike
elfin Robert hardball Patrick Madsen Lau
Ken and everyone else on my patreon
helping support me for this month and
making this video possible hope you guys
didn't mind a bit bought my face again
this time just thought sign you to
something a bit more visual to break up
from the footage of just limb perhaps
going up and down and a big thanks not
to just everyone I included in this
video but everyone who's maybe British
community water is today thank you to
everyone who's contributed to this
community and on a personal note thank
you to everyone that I've had the
pleasure of working with on my little
abridge and parody works really hope you
guys enjoyed it because there's always
been something I found in seining just
viewing from something that I've not
been completely into but it's just
something that I've had half of footage
anyway though that's it from me
I've been gigging and I will see you all
next time